okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have a special guest sarah garvey
welcome to the channel
thank you for having me thank you for
having me she takes a picture um before
i start guys do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
okay
so welcome to the show
um so i wanted to start um you have
about 60 000 subscribers on youtube yeah
so how did you get started on youtube
and what would you describe as like the
main message of your channel
um so i got started uh because i was a
debater in uh at a place called
speaker's corner in london
and basically speaker's corner is like a
place of freedom speech
people go there talk about everything
from race religion politics the monarchy
there's nothing is off limits at
speaker's corner so i was going there
for about maybe four years every sunday
from dusk till dawn and i got into
various debates
and what would happen is people would
film them on their phones upload them to
youtube
and
[Music]
you know some of the debates started you
know doing like
some numbers and i was like well it's
not my channel or someone else's channel
and so
i decided to kind of put my thoughts
into um
social commentating
because originally i used to be an actor
for a very long time ago about 20 years
ago
and so it's not like i'm not used to
being on camera so you know i've got a
best friend um called a dyke who's a
great videographer and you know one day
he was like listen let's get some of
your thoughts and feelings on camera
and so i started that about
two three years ago i think
and um it's just grown since then and
might so the main the main content of my
channel
i would say is social commentary and
freedom of thought um
i'm about freedom of thought freedom of
speech
you know the ability to hold a good
conversation
and debate well and articulate yourself
and i'm i'm a firm believer in agreeing
to disagree you know if people don't get
along
and um
yeah i think that's about it really yeah
that's actually so interesting i've
never heard of like a lounge where you
said it was like a lounge almost or like
a stage
it's a park it's a park it happens every
sunday in hyde park in london
and it's literally a place where you go
down to
express your views on any single topic
that you want um it can get a bit heated
sometimes because people have
differences of opinion as you can
imagine
but um
it's been running for about 150 years
over 150 years speaking oh wow
that's so cool
um so what was like the first debate of
yours that went viral
um it was a debate on religion
i debate
i debate uh religion quite a bit so it
was a
probably religious debate between myself
and
a muslim cleric or something down at the
corner
and um
yeah it kind of went viral because
people saying who is this guy
he can't speak about our religion like
this
you know yeah it was the first one to
kind of go viral so it's kind of what i
was known for initially with debate and
religion
it was debating religion i think my
light just died hold on
i guess not
um that's so so
what was uh
so you're known for debating religion
that's so interesting so are you like
were you taking like the atheist point
of view the christian point of view
um i'm not i'm not a follower of any
abrahamic religion so i'm a pantheist
myself which is you could say
agnostic-ish
okay um
so
however i studied the abraham religions
both jail christianity and islam
for like maybe 12 years okay um i
studied them to kind of you know
understand what they're about you know
the history of them so i had a little
bit of knowledge
on this stuff and then i just went down
there to debate it and um
it was it was an interesting time let's
just say that
um okay so what was was that the first
video that went viral was it on your
youtube channel or someone else's it was
on someone else's okay so what was the
first video that went like super viral
on your channel was that the one that i
reacted to
um it was probably i've done an
interview with someone over in the uk
called tommy robinson
um he's quite a controversial character
um over in the uk people say that he's a
racist people say that he's an
islamophobe
you know
and um he causes quite a lot of
controversy over here so i did an
interview with him
and that went viral
and that was a couple of years ago now
but the um
the one that you saw
uh f modern day women yeah
yeah it went viral about two months ago
and it's still doing the rounds now so
yeah yeah
no um that was it's interesting because
a lot of people like think that i would
be offended by some of the stuff you
were saying in the video like i think
you called modern women like entitled um
narcissistic yeah
um but i grew up with um nine siblings
so i feel like i've heard like every
like name someone can call you read a
book
but no it's definitely like i thought
what you said about um women wanting
chivalry but like not being like classic
women today was actually really
interesting um could you talk a little
bit more about like what the issues you
see with modern day women
um
yeah well like i said in the video um
i think there's a lot of
good women out there but i think a
certain type of woman has been molded
over this past five decades
and um
i feel like uh a sense of entitlement um
a sense of narcissism as well
and
and always needing to be right and never
wanting to listen
um there's a lot of those women i mean
i being someone who would call myself
part of the quote-unquote black
community
see it quite a lot amongst my community
sometimes and
but the thing is i think this
psychology has gone
global
i think um this this type of psychology
has gone global i think a lot of women
tend to exhibit these types of behaviors
and um
i speak to a lot of men and we've got a
lot of men in my circle
and some of the things they tell me
i'm like wow
and so i thought you know what
a lot of people thought that it came
from a um
the video actually came from a personal
place
but it's mostly stupid like what i'm
seeing
so
yeah that's why i kind of made the video
okay
um so what do you see as like the cause
of these problems do you think it's um i
know you talk a lot about like feminism
on your channel
um do you see it being feminism or do
you see it just like the way society is
shifting today
um i think feminism
uh let's say third fourth wave feminism
has a lot to do with it you know the
i think women for a long time were told
that you know they don't need no man
yeah they can do better without a man
and they're independent from a man
and
so what happened then is that i think
a lot of society and a lot of the
governmental structures started to
monetarily incentivize women to be
single yeah so um you know you can look
at
the uh
the welfare movement you know the
movement of welfare even in the uk we
have
um systems where
single women can get housing
you know they can get their rent paid
for they can get their chil they can get
money for their children and essentially
what that does
is emasculate the man
because it's kind of his role to do that
for
his woman like he has a purpose to do
that a lot of men have a purpose to do
that and so when a woman knows um
that the new man in her life is now the
state
or the government and they will provide
they will now provide for her
over
what the man would be initially
providing one it emasculates men and two
it makes women
dependent on someone other than
i guess their man
for the support that normally throughout
history we've been doing as men
so um i think it's it's layered yeah
well it also almost incentivizes like
bad decisions like you can make a bad
choice um and have absolutely no
consequence and if anything you almost
get a reward
right
um i mean one of the things i speak
about as well is abortion
and um
i will i'm what people call a pro-lifer
i'm not like a staunch
pro-lifer where you know so people
always bring in rape or molestation and
should a woman be able to should she
keep a rapist baby or something like
that and i always say no of course not
um
but bad decisions like
people having
unprotected sex and then using abortion
as basically contraception you know
um
like you said i think this society
incentivizes
bad behaviors
and um it actually incentivizes the
disconnect of the family unit as well
um
do you think that because one idea that
i was thinking about the other day
was that like i think birth control also
played a like a pretty big effect in
like the family structure today because
before it was like if you were like
sleeping with somebody like the odds are
where that you
may get pregnant from that interaction
and so like even my grandparents like
the reason they got married was because
like they were like my grandma was
pregnant um
but then when like they developed birth
control
like it kind of like delayed that
process you see like women having
children later and later and waiting
longer and longer to get married
um
yeah i mean it's a what they call the
sexual liberation movement yeah
and so um with the
with the coming of birth control
people were more
i guess women were more sexually
liberated um i don't have a problem with
quote-unquote sexual liberation per se
um
[Music]
but initially
well i guess we're seeing the effects
i guess
you sometimes when something starts you
never really see
the effects until like decades later and
so i think we're seeing the effects of
like a radical
feminist movement right now yeah
um
what
other legal incentives do you see
for women to make bad decisions um like
do you talk about that at all on your
channel like some of the legal
um just things that you'd like to see
different like legally
um
so i mean i've spoken about
a system
initially that is designed
you know for one of a better term as a
setup for men
because
i've i've spoken to many uh
because i'm a father myself and i speak
to many fathers who are going through
situations with the mothers of their
children and the courts normally favor
that favor the mother
um over the father um
i think a lot of this system
demonizes men when it comes to certain
situations
um
so you know when it comes to
uh
you know uh parental control of a child
they initially always say oh the mother
should have parental control over their
child as if fathers aren't able
to to be good parents you know um
so yeah i think
i think that the systems in which we've
been living under for the past maybe
five decades
are kind of starting to um
fray let's say yeah there's gonna be a
lot of revamping
of initial systems and you know the one
thing in life that is inevitable is
change but yeah with that there normally
comes some kind of pushback yeah people
are used to the old ways but um
i think a lot of things are going to
change within the next 10 to 15 years
yeah
do you think um
because i actually don't know a ton
about like the court system when it
comes to like legal rights for men um
like you know i've never been divorced
i've never had kids so i wouldn't really
know um do you think it's more like try
sometime
someday yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to get married
before i do that
right
um
but do you think like the court system
like it's more like internal like judges
just tend to think like like mothers
should be with their kids or are there
like actual laws in place that prevent
fathers from getting custody okay so in
the uk we have the children's act okay
or
1989 and within this act when you read
it and it was written by three women and
it was put through court legislation and
became legal and it's currently the
system that fathers
adhere to now
so within that uh
within the children's act it actually
states that mothers have the
sole responsibility of the child unless
the father acquires it
now this is only
if the two parents were not married
okay so
so so for instance i wasn't married to
my son's uh mother
we were engaged it doesn't matter
so
she now has custody of him and i have to
what they call acquire the right to have
um custody of him and so
yeah there's a lot of legal stuff that
needs to be revamped also i believe um
we had over here we have
a organization called fathers for
justice
and um
yeah they
they highlight the uh
the way in which the court system family
court system is very heavily skewed
towards women
what does that mean that they have to
acquire it does that mean like the mom
has to do something like it's it's like
a legal term and even i don't know what
it means
it's like it's a legal term it's that
wouldn't mean i have to acquire
my own child it's just a very weird
way of phrasing stuff that basically
shuts the father out of
having custody over his own
child his own flesh and blood
um
okay sorry i'm just trying to process
like
that's so that's such a broad
like term because it sounds like that
would just mean like the mom has to do
something like ungodly bad in order to
lose custody of the kids basically yeah
like more likely than not unless she's
like you know addicted to something or
like right
that she's gonna get there
can you
um
okay so
what about what do you think um would be
like legal solutions for this kind of
thing would you want that law to like
dissolve altogether
no i just think a revamp i think um
some real research into what is needed
with within the family unit and within
the family structure
um
having a re revamping of the laws
um i don't think that um
i don't think that totally just you know
getting rid of laws you know probably
the answer it just has it has to be a
gradual change as well because some
people are used to certain
certain ways but i do i said i
definitely think that
certain things need to change definitely
when it comes to um father's rights
okay um
so like
could i get like an example of something
like a small change you'd like to see
like a small change um
would be
as long uh i would think that both
parents should have equal rights
to the child
i think that's a small change that makes
sense
you know i think that makes sense i
don't think um
[Music]
when it comes to the family courts a lot
of stuff is um
let's say institutionalized as well
um the the way in which fathers are
viewed
as not as good parents as mothers is
institutional yeah you know it's within
society in general
you know people automatically think that
mothers are going to be the better
parent
over the father so
a lot of things while they may be
absolutely legal
they may have to be societal also
yeah it's interesting because um in my
opinion like before i stumbled upon like
the red pill and like the man of sphere
content like on my youtube channel
um
i really didn't hear a lot about like
issues that men have like legally they
don't really talk about it in like the
mainstream media yeah
um like there's a lot of like i had no
idea that that was um
like that it's so hard for like men to
get custody
yeah
it's hard i mean it's hard for men to
get custody it's easy for men to be seen
as the aggressor and in the video that
you reviewed i said um
you know a lot of the modern day women
will if they feel aggrieved by a man
will you know act as if they want to
fight him
yeah you know i've seen a lot of women
up in men's faces like they want to
fight and i'm
sitting there thinking
really do you really want to do that but
the only the only reason why a woman can
do that is because if she knows there's
a system
designed
to to always see her as the victim yeah
because if a man was going to even raise
his voice or you know push her or
whatever the man would all automatically
be seen as the aggressor whereas she
could be up in his face you know
pointing in his head you know doing all
that kind of stuff and it's like he's
just got to sit there and take it which
is enough which is another emasculation
process for the man it's like how am i
just supposed to stand here and allow
someone not just a woman or a man but a
person
to talk to me in a way that you know i
don't want to be spoken to and
physically touched me the way i don't
want to be physically touched but if i
was to retaliate i'd have the police at
my door you know what i mean like in
hangar i mean so it's like
yeah there's a lot of things within the
society that
um
need to be addressed i think can men let
not call the police on a woman like can
girls
yeah i mean they can but as a man being
a man myself yeah it doesn't run through
my head to call the police on a woman
unless she's really like i don't know
smashing windows or i don't know doing
something like really crazy but
generally men don't
don't feel the need to call
the police which is why a lot of men
uh are in abusive relationships with
women and no one knows
yeah
well that's another thing that i had no
idea about i didn't know either that a
lot of girls will like leverage the kids
like if um
if like a they have a kid together and
they break up and then the guy doesn't
like act the way she wants or do what
she wants like the girls will literally
like
like
not let the dad see the kids yeah um and
i'm just wondering like how is that
legal
um
because okay so i talk about parental
alienation yeah and one of the um
one of the major things in parental
alienation is to demonize
the father
so that when you're speaking to people
they say oh yeah i can definitely see
why you're keeping him away from his
child
so a lot of parents who have a parent
who wants to alienate their child will
say he's an abuser i don't know he's a
narcissist he's he's sexually assaulted
her he physically assaulted her
um
she stalks her she's scared of him you
know all this kind of stuff and so this
is how it becomes quite easy
as a matter of fact because if a woman
says that about a man she'll get
believed nine times out of ten yeah you
know um and that's not to say that
doesn't happen because if it does it's
not it's an unfortunate thing
but not every
that is why it is so easy
to um alienate a father from their child
because the woman can say he done x yl
zed
and she'll be believed
so and there's not really any
repercussions if she lies about
something is there
no
like i i can't imagine it's like super
common that a guy like presses charges
on a girl for lying about like abuse or
nurse like like that sort of thing i
want to say narcissism but you can't you
can't charge someone
i mean i made a video a couple of days
ago called what is a rapist
yeah
and
i made that video because there's a guy
in the uk he plays he plays for a major
um football team
and he's been accused of rape
and
he's been accused of rape
he hasn't been convicted of rape
and so one of my things is how how come
men that get accused of rape
have their whole life plastered all over
the media
whereas we don't know who's accusing him
and i'm not saying he isn't a rapist he
could be
but he's not convicted of a crime yet so
why do we know
all of his business and it's like i
think that's very unfair because the
term rape
and your name go together and people
don't care anymore they don't care
whether you're innocent or whether
you're guilty they just oh yeah he's a
rapist
and so you can get trial by media and i
was saying that that's a very unfair
thing so if women are found to be lying
or there's insufficient evidence they're
not going to be tried they're not going
to be charged they're not going to be
you know convicted of any crime but they
just get to you know say something and
walk away whereas a man's life can be
totally you know totally um
discombobulated after that do you think
if there's a lack of sufficient evidence
the woman should be tried then like she
should go to court
um
i don't think so because sometimes if
there's lack of physical evidence then
it doesn't mean there was no assault do
you know what i mean i think if someone
is found to be actually lying
about it then
yeah
i think they should be tried and i never
understood like the believe all women um
like notion because i know some girls
that like dude lie about literally
everything right so like how can you say
to believe
50 of the population just undoubtedly
that doesn't make any sense but then a
lot of women know that they'll be
believed as well yeah
do you know what i mean and so it
creates a
one of what what i was talking about it
creates a very
psychopathic
narcissistic
egotistical type person when you know
that you can lie and be believed you
know imagine you had that power imagine
i could say anything to you and i i knew
people are going to believe me like i
could abuse that wholeheartedly abuser
and i'm that's not me saying that all
women are like this but i'm saying
because the environment in which we live
um champion certain behaviors
behaviors it's very easy to do that
well i always say like it gets rid of
the consequence so like i
i think people
are more likely to do bad things if
there's no consequence
so like what what consequence does she
really have even like
even people that go to court and they're
not found guilty like
they still will like girls still can
like write a book and make a career out
of like one accusation
off of like a big name celebrity like
what what incentive is that to stop
doing it
um there is no real incentive yeah and
that's the thing there is no real
incentive and so you know what what
generally happens when i speak the way i
speak
you know a lot of women
say oh you hate women and
you're a misogynist and you're a toxic
masculinity
and i'm like no
like someone has to balance this thing
out now this thing has got to be
balanced out i think you know me trying
to like i talk a lot about um
red pill rage you like the red pill
community have a lot there's a lot of
angry men in the record
um
and so
when it comes to you know women
and the way the red some of the red
pills see women they're like where are
this and women
i hate them
and people try to you know i guess put
me in the same category and it's like no
you can get people in the red in the red
pool community and the manosphere who
are quite level-headed but they just
need to
rectify the balance of
the overcorrection that happened for the
five for the past five decades
yeah well i think that's why like
people watch my channel um because i
don't know how much you've seen but i
literally
just react to red pill content
right yeah and so people aren't really
used to seeing like a girl watch it and
not get offended and like mad
but
yeah i mean
a lot of women do though yeah and that's
the thing i think but then i think i've
always i've made so many different
videos um because i made one on what i
would call
i really are are you allowed to
curse on this channel i hope so i don't
know
no i
i could i had um a video called this
[ __ ] made generation yeah and um
literally this generation in my point of
view
it's just over-emotional it's like
they're waiting to be offended by
something it's like they go around the
internet
looking for things to be offended by and
then as soon as they're offended by it
they start flagging it and trying to
cancel people you know i mean trying to
make petitions and it's just like yo
like when did we get this sensitive i
don't understand yeah
i've always said like the day i get
canceled i know i'll make i i know i'll
have made it because you can't cancel
someone unless they have a following
um
i got cancelled once on on on
instagram they deleted my last instagram
account oh yeah
yeah so i got cancelled
i got canceled on tick tock once
i'll read it but it wasn't for anything
it was like so stupid i wore like a
kimono as a kid like when i was like 12
and like people didn't like that
oh so you what was that culture
appropriate yeah it was like for
halloween but i was like 12 i'm like
guys chill
so you showed if you showed something of
when you were 12 and people got upset
about it yeah because um
like um
my my family like dresses up as a fan
like i have nine siblings so we'll all
do like coordinated halloween costumes
or like boy or kid i'm 24 now but
um so i just did like a picture of like
our family and kimonos
and everyone was so mad but i don't know
that's the times we live in yeah people
are literally waiting for waiting for
something to be offended by yeah and
especially with sorry go ahead
no and so i think sometimes this is a
i can be quite sarcastic and so
sometimes i am
i purposely go for the for the things
people are going to be sensitive about
just to get just to see if they'll react
you know yeah um because i i feel like
we've got to grow
a bit of a thicker skin
nowadays there's a lot of things
happening and if we if we're sitting
around waiting to be offended
then it's going to be a long it's going
to be a long journey in this life
well even the video that i reacted to of
yours that was like [ __ ] modern day
women if you're not if you don't act
like that you shouldn't be offended by
it right like
why would i be offended by something
like
like what did you say um
non-traditional women spoiled brat like
bad stuff like i know i'm not that so
why do i care if you're saying that some
women are
but you see that non-traditional thing
is acid is very interesting because
you know
women were taught
they were taught it's taught like
bipolar or schizophrenia because it's
like
you don't need a man
right you don't need him he doesn't need
what you don't need him you could do for
yourself but when you do get one he must
shower you with everything and shower
you with gifts and bite and it's like
but hang on a minute well what happened
to i don't need a man now all of a
sudden when you get one yeah now he's
supposed to buy you everything and wrap
the world in a bowl like which one is it
like it's a little bit of a bipolar um
you know type thinking and so when men
like me pop up it's like i get confused
sometimes i'm like like what what is it
that you ladies want because yeah it
doesn't seem like you guys know what you
want
well and that's what because at some
point like i it's most of my channel is
like men that follow me but like i'd
really like to talk to like women
because one thing like i tell my friends
i'm like guys if you're always saying
like men are trash men are the problem
and you're confused why like none of
them will date you
like
like or i don't need a man it's like the
same thing like guys believe you
right like right
and so what's his purpose if you if you
tell a guy that you don't need a man
he's like
all right well i've got no purpose being
here then
yeah you know he's gonna he's gonna go
to someone that
that he feels like does need a man so if
you and if you display that energy that
okay you don't need a man then a man
will see that and be like okay well she
doesn't need me so
well and guys in general are so willing
like i grew up like my parents have been
married like
gosh i don't know almost 30 years maybe
um and like
it's crazy like if when my mom like
really appreciates my dad and like makes
him feel like like a king i guess the
best way i would say like he's willing
to do so much for her like so much like
work like super long days like i
remember like i went to
i forgot where it was like a picnic or
something and my dad literally like
carried my mom so her shoes wouldn't get
dirty
and it's because she like genuinely
treated him like a king like when he
came home like food was ready and like
but men are quite simple creatures and
we haven't changed like our needs
haven't changed much yeah i haven't
changed much over you know decades we're
pretty simple creatures um men generally
are trying to figure out women right
and we're trying to figure women out
and um i've always said well i've always
said as lately i've said
you women need to get together write a
manifesto all right let us know exactly
what it is you want because we're
confused now
that we are actually right we don't know
what
ladies
i feel like girls don't even know what
like they want because they'll say they
want one thing and then they'll date a
completely different like they'll say
they want the nice guy but like they'll
stay with the guy that's cheated them on
them like three times so it's like okay
so what are you sorry for me what is
that because i need to know what that as
a woman what do you think that is
if a woman does that
um
i mean i think there's like
like staying with a guy that cheated on
you or like not going or saying you want
something and like both okay um
this is kind of how i see it like i
think a lot of girls like see like red
flags early and you kind of see like how
this guy is but you're like attracted to
something about him maybe
um right and you're kind of just hoping
like you'll be the girl that changes him
all right so
this is the thing like i think that's
this is the thing that i try to get
through to women
because they try a woman tried to do the
same thing to me once which is why it
it's why i asked you just to see if it
was the the the correct answer
so you're you get attracted to somebody
with an edge
because that's what attracted you to
yeah okay and then all of a sudden
as you get more comfortable
the edge starts to
you start to wanna i guess sand down the
edge you know you wanna make the edge a
little bit smoother but then what you do
is that you um
you take away from
what you're attracted to in the first
place
yeah well i think sometimes like
that edge isn't good for like long-term
relationships you know
like sometimes like the thing that
attracted girls to them isn't
like it kind of gets old after a while
right
so like in a long-term relationship it's
not overly like sustainable i guess
okay so when you were saying also that
you know women say they want a certain
type of guy and then go for another guy
um
you know
there's a saying nice guys finish lost
you know that's satan's been around for
a very very long time yeah and um i
guess the older i've got the kind of
i've been like
you know what sometimes sometimes they
do a lot like they do nice guys do
finish last a lot
and um
but the type of woman who stays with a
guy who treats her like
absolute [ __ ] like i don't like what is
that
um
what is that
that's hard um
because we're trying to understand out
here
um
what is that i mean i don't
um
sorry i'm like trying to give a good
well thought out answer i would say
girls
like
start to become more like
at least my friends but i i have to say
like i grew up in a very like privileged
upbringing like all my friends parents
were married
um my parents were like i i grew up in a
very different environment than some
people but for me like
it only lasts for so long like after a
while like they end the girls end up
either dumping them or the guy ends up
like cheating and then they end up
leaving and like marrying a guy they can
more see a future with
but
i know there's some girls that like do
that into their 30s and 40s i just like
don't know them
so
so a woman who stays with a guy who's
constantly cheating
yeah treats are like crap yeah
she's constantly crying to her friends
yeah but then she's constantly going
back to them
because as men
our threshold is different if a woman's
constantly treating us a certain way or
whatever
at some point in time we're going to be
like all right see you later yeah
whereas women will stay around for
longer
yeah i just don't know any girls that
didn't leave eventually
right okay like that's what i'm saying
like they do it for so like my sister is
one i can think of my oldest sister
um she was married to a guy for like 10
years and i don't want to like put her
business out there but he like
he was not good
um but then like after 10 years she just
got tired of it and left him and like
married a different guy and had like
more kids with him and like now her new
husband's great
um
so
i feel like there was a there was a tv
show on netflix there was a show on
netflix called um sex life did you see
that
right and it was basically about this
married woman had the perfect life
perfect like
however she kept wondering about this
bad guy that she'd been with in the past
and she kept on pining for him and all
this kind of stuff whereas on the
surface
her life was perfect
um
but i feel like i don't know maybe
i don't know what that is in the in in
the psyche
of females that does that well i think
they talk about it like in the
manosphere they call it like the alpha
guy and the beta guy like they want the
alpha guy like to hook up with but they
want to have like and even have their
kids but they want the beta guy to like
raise them
i don't know how like
because it's hard because i can't you
can't really define alpha and beta
so that's where i get kind of like
tricky with the manosphere but
what makes you want to
learn about the manosphere though as a
woman
um
i really like psychology
so i think the psychology of dating is
really interesting
um yeah i would say like that's the main
reason i learned and it's like
interesting to hear like
the what guys try to do to like get
girls like i don't know
like it's like oh i know that game i
don't know like
um because some of it like i i've
learned like some stuff from like pickup
and like building girls like investment
and like attachment i thought that stuff
was really interesting too
i think i think um
the manosphere is um
a space for men to really i guess air
what they've been thinking about
women for a long time
and i think a lot of women are
interested they might not like what they
hear yeah
and they might not like what they hear
but
i think women can definitely i guess put
their ear in the conversation and be
like oh okay yeah that's how they think
you know um
and it helps you too like i think it
helps girls be a better partner to
understanding how guys think
um like even me like there's been stuff
where like with my boyfriend like i felt
like
like i took back and was like oh i see
like why he thinks this way
or like like why or like something i
could do like better you know like as a
girlfriend
right and
the thing is with
that's interesting because the thing is
with um
women wanting to know i i what i've
noticed is when women are in their
spaces
they don't want men in the space no
they don't want men in the space but the
thing is they will talk they will talk
about men in that yeah right
but
if a ma a man needs to know what women
think like so he's going to want to go
into the space
[Laughter]
all right
no i'm saying like you don't like the
way girls talk about men is like i'm
always the victim it's always me he
cheat like
it gets so old
like because girls always look at
themselves as the victim instead of like
taking accountability for who you choose
oh where'd you go
oh sorry could you hear me yeah now i'm
back you're back
oh i don't think i can hear you
can you hear me
you can't hear me um let me see
[Music]
all right in the chat can you guys hear
both of us
here
wait can you guys hear me
okay you can hear me
okay
also let me know if there's any like
questions that you guys have in the chat
um can you hear me yeah i can hear you
right i'm here i'm back sorry about that
no it's okay
um
okay someone in the chat says that they
think that men should take some
responsibility for some of this do you
think that's true or false for some of
what exactly
um i think we were talking about when um
you logged off like that women always i
was saying that like i think that women
always put themselves as the victim
um because in my head like
it's it's your own fault who you date
nobody's forcing you to like date those
type of guys so if you think guys are
toxic like you should probably look in
the mirror and think who am i dating
um
that's just my opinion though
i mean there are toxic men and toxic
women out there yeah
i think
generally we're all kind of hip to who's
toxic and who's not
and
uh
yeah it's kind of you you see you do see
signs you ignore them you know you see
red black ignore them
and it's just part and parcel of um i
don't know i think it's a human
experience i don't know
i'm
just trying to figure it out so i don't
know what
when they say they want men to take more
responsibility i'm just trying to figure
out on what exactly
yeah
um you can let us know in the chat guys
i think that was
eon001 who put that
um
okay so in terms of like a solution what
do you see other than like legally like
what can girls do to be part of the
solution rather than the problem
oh wow um introspection
introspection
um
[Music]
reflection
and a lot of um
asking yourself questions
before you react to something
i think um
i mean that's easy to say as a man
because we do that all the time right so
like
we ask ourselves okay is this okay is
that good does that do
i think women can become more
introspective
and and more truthful as well i think
for the motivations and why they do
certain things because
um
a lot of the time women know exactly why
they do certain things right
but they will act as if
it's something else i think i have an
example sorry okay so
women acting
as if they what they know what they're
doing but they're not
yeah
right
so okay so women will know
for instance
that
they are dating this guy because
he does he is a bad boy and she is
attracted to them right
but
she will tell her friends that she wants
the nice guy just be just be honest oh
okay you know just be honest and say
i'm attracted to this
because it makes me feel this way
right
and
that's that do you know what i mean
whereas yeah i think we hear a lot of
women
lying about stuff i mean even us we're
just like really you know
i think there's a little bit more behind
what you're saying i think men are
becoming more honest
in the manuscript because if you look at
the manosphere and the red pool
community men are just being honest yeah
they're not holding any punches
they are being honest and what what
what i tend to find is that honesty is
coming from a logical place whereas if
you take kevin samuels for example who
kind of
literally ignited the manosphere and
read
that community um you will find that a
lot of the women that go on his um
on his uh on his uh platform
that when they speaking about what they
want
i think sometimes they know it's
unrealistic
right but they're still saying and it's
like well
why are you saying this if you know
itself
who are you lying to right now yeah
wow do you guys do women lie to
themselves that much that they believe
the lie
like a guy will know his limits well
girls even lie to each other
like
like the one
what tell me more about that well like i
think of like the body positivity
movement
um that's like what came to my head
because when i think of kevin samuels i
think of like him calling a girl a
linebacker
um but it's like kevin tells you you're
gonna have more options than like higher
value men to date if you lose weight
right like that's something girls won't
say to each other they'll say you're
beautiful every size
um you're valuable no matter what like
any guys should be able to see you no
matter what size you are and you know
that sounds nice like i'd love to be
able to just eat whatever i want and
have no consequences but that's just not
honest that's not true
um guys look at like you get more
attention when you're thinner it's just
you know
or like slim thick like the you know
right i was gonna say yeah
it gets a little bit technical nowadays
well
yeah i mean there's the the like as you
said the bbl's and whatever
um it gets a bit technical so so why do
women lie to women like that then
no we're not confrontational i think
like i don't think women i think
naturally like you know women
like historically they can't disagree
with too many people because otherwise
they're in like the
like they're not the protector you know
right so i
i also think a lot of women don't like
other women
i think a woman
and that correct me if i'm wrong i think
a woman generally
when another woman walks in is sizing
her up she's looking at her hair her
makeup body
looking at her shoes
she's looking at something that
and a lot of them feel inadequate
compared to another woman
um i would say that's a lot with girls
that put a lot of like their value
into their looks so i think for like the
i've seen that the most with like the
prettiest like the most attractive girls
right because like you know for them
like that's that's who they are that's
their value that's the one thing they've
been recognized for like probably from
as long as they can remember
so like if another girl comes in that's
like taking attention away from them
like
it
you know they're they're more offended
than like you know you're more average
girls
right
or they take it more personally
that's i would say would you is that
what you've seen or would you say that's
always um no i think you have a point
there i think you have a point um i
think if you pin all of your hopes and
dreams on the way you look then
um it shows
as much as it may show confidence on the
outside it also shows a lot of
insecurity
yeah well and your your looks are a
depreciating asset as a girl like
it's not getting better
right
um which is why maybe you should not
invest
so much time and energy into the way you
look i'm not going to say don't look
good to somebody
but when you invest all of your time and
energy and that's how you now view
yourself as something that just needs to
be pretty all the time yeah
yeah you're setting yourself up for
failure there yeah no i
i definitely don't i wish sometimes i
wish i was like better at girl stuff i'm
kind of a tomboy to be honest right
um
okay so more about like potential
solutions so you said um
accountability accountability
yeah
um
is there anything else you'd add to that
list
um how can you answer it
i think that's a good start i think
honestly accountability and
introspection is a good start
okay
and i also think women need to start
calling other women out because i said
um in another video of mine that um men
are having to do
women's job in the fact that if a man
does something
um other men will call him out on it
and
i feel like women
don't call other women out
they let them do the bad behaviors and
oh yeah it's okay it's okay it's it's
fine it's like
no please like because we don't wanna
because when we call women out as men
yeah we get called
chauvinistic or
you know what i mean
we're just playing toxic masculinity and
stuff like that
so
i would say
i would like women to start
calling other women out
on bad behaviors for what what kind of
bad behaviors would you like women like
when do you think it's appropriate to
call someone out on their bad behavior
versus that does this not my life
doesn't affect me
okay so i said we were talking earlier
on about the court system and women
keeping yeah you know children from
their fathers and stuff like that
that's a bad behavior yeah
do you know what i mean but a lot of
women
don't call other women out on it you
know they let it be they they know that
their friend and also as a man i don't
i'm around a lot of men who are fathers
and
i encourage all the men around me
to see their children if they're not
or to get to do the best thing to see
their children so if i know a man's not
looking after his children i'll call him
out on it i say you know what he's do
better than that because your child
needs a father they need to you know
need to be raised you know they need a
strong man in the house before and i
would do that as men but
i don't know women a lot of women seem
to champion
other women that they know
are you know like making it difficult
for a father to see their child
yeah well
i think
i don't know so much about like the
um like i've never been in a situation
or had a friend in a situation like that
but i've noticed one thing about women
calling out or the reason some women
don't call out bad behavior um and i'm
thinking more like getting super drunk
like you know hooking up with random
guys like that sort of thing is a lot of
times like girls don't like to be alone
in their bad decisions
so if they're making a bad decision like
they don't want to be by themselves
right
um like i always use the analogy like in
school when you had a test and you
failed it like the worst feeling is
being the only one that failed
right
and like it's the best feeling when you
turn around and say like
oh you failed too it's not just me
like so sometimes i think that's like
part of the reason girls don't call each
other out is like
then they'd have to like look in the
mirror you know yeah
um
but i'm trying to see if there's any
other top we've like moved through a lot
um
oh and then the last thing i wanted to
get your thoughts on the red pill would
you describe yourself as red pilled
i would say so to some degree okay i
would say so um
like i said there's a lot of uh
red pool rage going on out there
i'm not part of that group yeah um i
don't
i definitely want women to be more
accountable and i definitely think
relationships need to overhaul
and you know we need to be more
more introspective and a little bit more
let's say
understanding of one another and who we
are but you know all that rage and women
of this and women are that and i think
it it all gets lumped in because when
you start to hear the same
types of talking points
from other people
you you generally lump them in with oh
they're just those people that those are
those people those are in cells those
are red those are these do you know what
i mean and it's like
no there's definitely nuance within
the red pill community i think so yeah
um
but yeah i would describe myself as red
polish
yeah okay
okay well thank you so much for coming
on the channel i really appreciate it
thank you
um is there any social medias you wanted
to shout out yeah you can follow me on
youtube right here on youtube sarah
garvey is my name um you can follow me
on
twitter
and instagram and facebook sara garvey
put it in
i'll come up
and um
yeah thank you for having me on yeah
thanks for coming don't forget guys to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell um and i will talk to
you guys next time